d'année il ya tout juste un an le 9
janvier 2003 la petite estelle alors
âgée de 9 ans disparaissait à guermantes
en seine-et-marne
malgré des moyens considérables la
fillette reste introuvable
aucune piste précise même si la police
désormais convaincus qu'il s'agit d'un
enlèvement prémédités mûrement préparée
à guermantes où les habitants restent
traumatisés une marche silencieuse sera
organisée demain matin retour sur cette
mystérieuse affaire avec philippe castel
et philippe hermant doigt des battues
avaient été organisées des lacs sont des
défauts réfugiés mais est elle reste un
tout va elle a disparu le 9 janvier vers
18h à guermantes sans doute près de
cette boulangerie
personne n'a rien vu et ça fait m le
père d'estelle depuis se refuse à
imaginer l'inacceptable j'ai pas envie
de devenir le spécialiste du scénario de
l'horreur donc c'est parti là nous
présentons ce que vous êtes découragé
n'ont jamais retrouvé
bien sûr neuf enquêteurs de la police
judiciaire de versailles travail à temps
plein sur le site estelle il ya six mois
un portrait robot a été tirée et une
voiture suspecte désigné jamais une
enquête n'a bénéficié d'autant de moyens
450 policiers gendarmes ont auditionné
l'ensemble de la population de
guermantes
et les interrogatoires ont été menées
plus récemment dans les milieux
pédophiles de toute la france pour
aboutir à une conviction n'a pu
déterminer que ce fait était très
vraisemblablement imputable à un
individu disons un pédophile à ce que
l'on appelle un prédateur c'est à dire
un individu qui qui s'est donné les
moyens de piste est une jeune fille peut
être pas forcément estelle de la suivre
et au moment où elle se trouvait seule
sans qu' il y ait grand monde autour
d'elle et bien deux
de l'inciter à de l'apprendre de son
fils avec elle outre cette thèse est
partagée par le père d'estelle qui se
souvient d'une tentative d'enlèvement
opéré quelques jours auparavant à
guermantes jeudi de la dernière semaine
de classe du mois de décembre
une petite fille avait fait l'objet
d'une tentative d'enlèvement qui
heureusement n'a pas pu se produire
estelle a été enlevé la première semaine
de la rentrée des classes
le même jour à la même heure donc
effectivement à la préméditation semble
établi un an plus tard le père d'estelle
combat un autre danger
l'oubli est donc une marche silencieuse